well after eight admissions employees
walked off the job at the animal
foundation the CEO Hillary gray says it
can be a stressful job for some of those
workers Victoria Saha reached out to
other shelters in our area on the job of
caring for animals in need
ing is a big issue not just for the
animal foundation but for other shelters
across the country as well and here at
Nevada SPCA I'm told they're also
dealing with a high volume of animals
coming in but they have measures in
place to take care of their animals and
employees too Nevada SPCA is currently
home to 260 animals it's 10 more than
what they're normally able to care for
this is one of the hardest jobs I've
ever had while it's not close to the
near 800 plus animals at the animal
foundation as PCA executive director
Lori Herron says she's doing her best to
make sure employees don't get
overwhelmed in January she says she went
to the board of directors to increase
pay for her workers that too is an issue
for the eight workers that walked out
from the animal foundation and get a
real sense of what's going on with them
and prevent incidents that like what it
occurred at the animal foundation in a
letter by the staff that resigned they
say they had to work 10 plus hours with
no breaks CEO of animal foundation
Hilary gray responded um we've made some
changes to scheduling and to other
things that affect the work environment
yes wages are an issue when talking with
some of the employees who are left at
the animal foundation and they tell me
they're willing to sit down with gray to
go over changes Victoria Saha 8 News Now